sarah fergie ferguson says she totally
understands why the royal family didn't
invite her to prince william and kate
middleton's wedding back in 2011.
the 61 year old duchess of york is the
ex-wife of prince andrew and the mother
to william's cousins
princess beatrice and princess eugenie
and was noticeably absent from the duke
and duchess of cambridge's nuptials
which took place shortly after she was
caught on camera promising a reporter
access to prince andrew
in exchange for 500 000 pounds
which for reference converts to about
690
thousand dollars now she's opening up to
town and country magazine and
addressing the controversy quote i
didn't think i was probably worthy to go
to their wedding
i took myself to thailand actually to be
far away from it
so that i could try and heal and while
fergie didn't get the invite to kate and
william's i do's
she did get one for prince harry and
meghan markle's 2018 wedding
and she thanked them on good morning
britain after the big day
was very kind of them and i think i
think that
i can't i can't thank them enough for
doing that because it was
it was nerve-wracking and the crowd were
all cheering that must have been a great
likes to cry i mean it must have been
well it was it was quite extraordinary i
i really sort of looked around and
thought are they sort of doing it for me
and then some went fergie and it was the
old fergie back you know and i
felt that sense of support as for the
rift between william and harry
fergie declined to comment but did say
this
quote i believe that princess diana
would be so
proud of her boys and she'd be so proud
of her grandchildren
there's clearly still a lot of hurt a
lot of resentment
and a degree of mistrust i think on both
parts
fergie's statement echoes what royal
expert katie nicol told
et leading up to the brothers reunion
earlier this month to unveil a statue of
their late mother
on what would have been her 60th
birthday diana always said to them
boys stay close don't ever fall out she
would be devastated that that is what's
happened
and she would be wanting them to feed
her together for that unveiling of the
statue in her honor
the unveiling came amid reports that the
brothers are at odds
following harry's decision to step back
from his senior royal duties in 2020
and his explosive tell-all interview
with oprah winfrey earlier this year
i think both of them have wanted today
to be
about the statue about remembering
diana's legacy
and not about the rift that has really
overshadowed the coverage
of the royal family for the past 18
months now so
they clearly went to a lot of effort to
deflect from this rift
between the two of them and instead to
project on
their mother a legacy and crucially
putting on a united front to remember
diana their mother
on what would have been her 60th
birthday noticeably absent from the
unveiling
harry's wife megan who gave birth to the
couple's second child
lillabet diana just weeks earlier in
june
and on monday the palace announced that
the tiny tot has
officially been added to the royal line
of succession
lillabet is eighth in line to the
british throne one placed behind her big
brother
archie and two behind her dad who is
currently
sixth in line to queen elizabeth's
throne as for harry
the 36 year old announced earlier this
month that he plans to release a memoir
in 2022 that will cover quote
experiences adventures losses and life
lessons that have helped shape him
there are still many parts of harry's
life particularly his younger life
that have yet to be explored and he has
promised us a no-holds-barred
autobiography a memoir in which he is
able to be wholly truthful about his
life a memoir that will surely
have the royals very nervous very
apprehensive about exactly what's to
come
we've learned from harry that when he
does these
tell-alls they really are exactly that i
mean if you look at the oprah
interview it was explosive so i think
we're expecting the same thing from a
[Music]
book